all the great speed improvements of
Android 2.0 and everything you need to
be able to take full advantage of the
Android and Developer Preview plus a
bunch of bug fixes and stability
improvements I'm reto Meier it's Android
tool time time and this is Android
studio 2.1 installing the Android and
preview SDK requires Android studio 2.1
as well as an specific bug fixes it also
supports the N Developer Preview
emulator system images it also allows
you to use the New Jack compiler but
note that Jack doesn't currently support
instant run Jack does support many Java
eight language features such as lambda
expressions our lambda implementation
uses anonymous classes making their use
backwards compatible if you target
Android n Jack also supports to a fault
and static interface methods repeatable
annotations and method references though
they are not backwards compatible
Android studio 2
1includes speed improvements to instant
run making it significantly faster for
instance to reduce compilation time the
incremental Java compiler feature is now
enabled by default if you've allocated
enough memory to the Gradle daemon we
also enabled axing in process by default
which performs dexing within the build
process rather than a separate external
vm process aside from these features
Android studio 2.1 also includes a
number of bug fixes and stability
improvements especially fuses with the
Android and preview SDK installed you
know the last time Android studio did a
point update with mainly bug fixes it
was right before a major release uh yeah
yeah I guess you're right and right
before a pretty big developer conference
and isn't Google IO coming up yeah may
18 May 18 it's just a coincidence though
I wouldn't I wouldn't read too much into
it
sure right so can we look in the box
really prefer to be didn't upgrade to
Android studio 2.1 to play with the new
Android and develop a preview get FASTA
instant run and take advantage of a
bunch of bug fixes and stability
improvements this is an der studio 2.1
and this is under a tool time time